>>> THE SQUAD IS BACK FOR NFL
KICKOFF WEEK.
THAT'S ONLY NINE DAYS LEFT UNTIL
THE RETURN OF FOOTBALL.
WE'LL GET YOUR TAKE ON OUR
FAVORITE MARKETS FOR RUSHING
YARDS TO ROOKIE OF THE YEAR TO
MVP AND MORE!
>>> WE'RE ALSO GIVING AWAY
KILLER PRIZES INCLUDING NFL
JERSEYS, OVER A THOUSAND DK
DOLLARS AND ALL EXPENSES PAID
TRIP TO LAS VEGAS FOR ONE LUCKY
PERSON AND A FRIEND.
IT'S NOT A COMMERCIAL!
IT'S A LIVE SHOW!
LET'S GO!
>>> WELCOME TO "THE SQUAD"
BROUGHT TO YOU BY DRAFT KINGS
LIVE IN THE BLEACHER REPORT AT
NFL KICKOFF IS RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER.
I'M CONNOR ROGERS.
JOINING ME IS THE MAN OF THE
PEOPLE, THE GUY YOU WANT TO GET
ON HIS GOT SIDE.
HE HAS A LOT TO GIVEAWAY TODAY.
THAT'S GREG IVORY.
NOT ONE BUT TWO NFL LEGENDS IN
VINCE YOUNG AND KEITH TALIB.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE.
HOW ARE WE FEELING?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> HELL, YEAH.
>> YEAH.
>> YES, SIR.
YES, SIR.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
TO KICK THINGS OFF, WE'LL TAKE A
LOOK AT THE BEST MOMENTS FROM
LAST SEASON WITH A LITTLE HELP
FROM YOU, THE FANS.
♪
♪ ♪
YEAH!
(
♪ ♪
>> MAN, IT FEELS GOOD TO WIN.
I'LL TELL YOU THAT MUCH.
WE TEAMED UP WITH A DRAFT KINGS
TO GIVE A LOOK AT OUR BEST BETS.
A LOT OF IN-DEPTH AND DIFFERENT
ODDS AND SORTS LIKE THAT.
WHAT ELSE WE GOT IN STORE, MAN?
>> CONNOR, WE GOT A LOT.
IT'S A DAY SHOW.
I'M GOING TO BE GIVING OUT OVER
A THOUSAND BK DOLLARS.
FIVE NFL JERSEYS, A TRIP TO LAS
VEGAS FOR YOU AND A FRIEND, AND
AS ALWAYS, ALWAYS, ALWAYS,
HOODIES, HOODIES, HOODIES.
I FEEL LIKE GIVING OUT ONE RIGHT
NOW!
EVERYBODY THAT'S TAPPED INTO THE
SQUAD KNOW WHAT THIS IS HERE.
AQUIB, TY, CONNOR, THIS IS THE
iPAD.
THIS IS HOW EVERYBODY WILL GET
HOODIES.
HOW YOU GET YOUR MONEY.
HOW YOU GET JERSEYS.
THIS HERE IS THE PLUG.
I NEED YOU TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHO YOU
WOULD TRUST TO CASH YOUR BET.
A STAR QUARTERBACK OR LOCKDOWN
DEFENSE?
I'M GIVING AWAY 250 DK DOLLARS
AND A JERSEY.
BEFORE I DO THAT, TALK TO ME.
WHO WOULD YOU RATHER HAVE?
A STAR QUARTERBACK OR LOCKDOWN
DEFENSE?
>> YOU HAVE TO GO WITH YOUR
BOY -- AQUIB, COME ON, MAN.
WHICH WAY YOU LEANING?
WHICH WAY YOU GOING?
>> I'M RIDING WITH HIM.
GOING WITH THE QUARTERBACK.
WANT TO BET ON THE LEAST AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE.
THE DEFENSE YOU HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT TOO MANY PEOPLE.
THE QUARTERBACK, MAN, ONE-MAN
SHOW.
>> YEAH.
>> I'M GOING TO BE THAT LAS
VEGAS TRIP.
I'M GOING TAKE THAT.
>> HEY!
HOW WE APPLY FOR THAT?
HOW WE APPLY?
YEAH.
>> LAS VEGAS.
LAS VEGAS TRIP MIGHT BE
LEGENDARY.
WE MIGHT WANT TO TALK TO THE
PRODUCERS ABOUT THAT ONE.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS.
I'M INTO THE COMMENTS AND SEEING
STAR QUARTERBACK LIKE NO OTHER.
I'M SEEING STAR QUARTERBACK.
THE COMMENTS ARE MOVING SO FAST.
HOLD ON.
I HAVE TO LOCK IN.
HERE WE GO.
KP PHILLY 330 IS WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
RAIDERS 0818 A HOODIE.
I'M GOING GIVE OUT THE JERSEY
NOW.
I'M GOING TO GIVE OUR THE JERSEY
AND DK DOLLARS.
THE JERSEY IS GOING TO -- HERE
WE GO.
I GOT JACK ZAMINS.
GOING WITH LOCKDOWN DEFENSE WINS
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IN
THE COMMENTS.
I KNOW YOU LIKE THAT.
>> YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
HEY.
I'M GOING GIVEAWAY THE JERSEY
NOW.
I'M GIVING AWAY THE JERSEY.
HERE WE GO IN THE COMMENTS AND I
HAVE NOT DJ METCALFE SAYS STAR
QUARTERBACK.
THAT'S THE ONE PERSON I CHOSE.
SO SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
CONNOR?
LET'S GET IT GOING.
>> YEAH.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK WHAT THE
AUDIENCE HAVE TO SAY.
STAR QUARTERBACK FOR THE
LOCKDOWN DEFENSE.
WE'RE KNOW HOW WE'RE FEELING
OVER HERE.
IT'S A LOPSIDED ANSWER.
THEY'RE TAKING THE STAR
QUARTERBACK.
>> NOT MUCH OF A SURPRISE THERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
KEEP THIS THING MOVING.
LET'S GET TO WHAT THE AUDIENCE
HAS BEEN WAITING FOR.
IT'S TIME TO TALK OUR FAVORITE
BETS.
LET'S DIVE IN.
WE'RE STARTING WITH RUSHING
YARDS.
THERE'S BEEN A TOP DOG IN THIS
CATEGORY FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
A LOT OF PLAYERS WITH BIG
EXPECTATIONS THIS YEAR.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THOSE TOTALS
FOR RUSHING YARDS.
OVER/UNDER.
HERE IS THE TOP EIGHT RIGHT
HERE.
OBVIOUSLY, A LOT OF DIFFERENT
EXPECTATIONS.
OF COURSE, THE EXPECTATIONS ARE
REALLY, REALLY HIGH FOR
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY RETURNING
THIS YEAR.
THE YOUNG BUCK IN JONATHAN
TAYLOR.
NICK CHUBB EXPECTED TO HAVE A
HUGE SEASON.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU NEED FROM THE
PEOPLE NOW AS YOU SEE THE
RUSHING YARD TOTALS?
>> I NEED EVERYBODY IN THE
COMMENTS.
GET IN THE COMMENTS.
START TYPING AND TELL US WHO IS
GOING TO HAVE THE MOST RUSHING
YARDS?
WHO DO YOU THINK?
WHAT IS THE BEST BET FOR RUSHING
YARDS?
WHAT IS YOUR BEST BET FOR
RUSHING YARDS.
WHAT IS YOUR BEST BET?
YOU CAN TELL ME IN WORDS.
YOU CAN TELL ME IN EMOJIS OR
GIFS.
GET CREATIVE!
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND
GIVING AWAY $250 DK DOLLARS.
WHO DO YOU THINK IS THE BEST
RUSHING YARD BET ON THE BOARD?
>> THAT'S EASY.
TIGHTEN UP, FIRST OF ALL.
GO WITH THE BIG GUY.
IT'S GOING TO BE OVER.
DEFINITELY OVER.
>> YEAH.
>> AQUIB, WHO ARE YOU ROLLING
WITH?
>> I'M RIDING WITH CHRISTIAN
McCAFFREY.
YOU KNOW, SAM DOLLAR IN HOLD
TAKING THE PRESSURE OFF HIM.
HE'S DUE FOR A BIG YEAR.
HE'S READY TO GO IF.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I'M GOING WITH JONATHAN TAYLOR.
>> VINCE, GO AHEAD.
>> OKAY.
>> GO AHEAD, VINCE.
>> YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT'S NOT A GOOD ONE.
WHY?
>> BECAUSE DONALD?
THAT GUY?
DARNOLD?
>> I SAW HIM PLAY TOO MUCH.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
SO GOOD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT THAT MEAN THEY'RE GOING TO
LEAN ON THE RUN GAME.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
THAT'S PART OF MY REASONING
THERE.
>> LET'S NOT GET THAT.
HOLD ON.
>> HE STAYED HEALTHY.
I THINK HE COULD.
>> EASY WORK.
>> YEAH.
I'M KIND OF THINKING WHAT KEITH
IS THINKING ONLY A DIFFERENT
TEAM.
I'M GOING WITH JONATHAN TAYLOR.
THE KWOLT COLTS HAD ALL KIND OF
QUARTERBACK PROBLEMS.
WHATEVER IS GOING ON WITH WENTZ.
THEY'LL HAND TAYLOR THE BALL A
LOT.
WE SAW WHAT HE DID IN 13 GAMES
LAST YEAR.
ABSOLUTELY KILLING IT.
SO TAYLOR EASY OVER.
HAMMER IT.
WHAT DO YOU GOT, GREG?
>> AH, I MEAN, BEFORE I GET INTO
MY PICK, LET ME GET INTO THE
COMMENTS.
I'M A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
I WANT TO HEAR WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
I GOT JAMES ROBERTSON ABOUT TO
GET ALL THE TOUCHES.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
THE COMMENTS ARE GOING TODAY.
I GOT DOUBLE D SAYS MC SQUARED
ACKMC.
HE'S ROCKING WITH YOU, AQUIB.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
HE'S WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
AND HERE WE GO.
HERE WE GO.
I'M GIVING OUT ONE MORE HOODIE.
JOSHUA LOPEZ 10.
HEY!
MY COLLEGE TEAMMATE.
>> HEY.
>> WHAT UP.
HE SAID RAHIM MOSER.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, JOSH.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
BEFORE I GIVE OUT THE DOLLARS,
LET ME HOP IN.
LET ME HOP IN HERE.
I SAW A GUY BY THE NAME OF
EZEKIEL ELLIOT.
ONLY HAVING TO RUSH FOR 1 --
1100 YARDS.
ZEKE RUSHED FOR THE 979 LAST
YEAR.
GET IT.
GET THE YARDS.
I'M TAKING THE BET.
AH!
LET ME GIVE OUT THE $250 DK
DOLLARS.
HERE WE GO.
I'M USED TO BEING ON THE STAIN
GRAM.
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
AND I SEE.
>> OH!
THIS IS A GOOD ONE.
♪ ♪
>> GUY WITH WATER.
>> SMART MAN.
JOSH JACOBS.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> JOSH JACOBS.
SHOUTOUT TOW YOU.
>> DK DOLLARS.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> MORE MONEY.
MORE MONEY, AQUIB.
GOOD BETS.
LIKE THESE ONES TODAY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND VISIT DRAFT KINGS FOR MORE
RUSHING YARD TOTALS.
WE'LL KEEP IT MOVING.
A LITTLE MORE FUN.
OVER/UNDER.
ANYONE CAN DO THAT.
LET'S PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTH IS FOR RUSHING TOUCHDOWNS.
LEADER.
YOU PICKED ONE HERE.
OBVIOUSLY THE REIGNING KING THE
TWO-TIME KING DEREK HENRY AT THE
TOP.
HE'S DONE IT THE LAST TWO YEARS.
A LOT OF CONTENDERS IN THE POOL
THIS YEAR.
OBVIOUSLY NICK CHUBB HUGE
EXPECTATIONS THERE IN CLEVELAND.
ZEKE GOING TO BE GETTING THE
GOAL LINE CARRIES.
AARON JONES COMING OFF REALLY
GOOD BACK TO BACK YEARS FOR
GREEN BAY.
IF YOU DIDN'T GET THOSE WITHIN
DON'T WORRY.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY MORE NOW.
TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT IS IN
STORE.
>> I'M ATTENDANT TO TAP IN WITH
AQUIB TALIB AND ASK HIS PICK WHO
HE THINKS WILL HAVE THE MOST
RUSHING TOUCHDOWNS THIS SEASON.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS
ONE MORE TIME.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS.
PLEASE GET THE ODDS UP.
WE HAVE DEREK HENRY.
DALVIN COOK.
OH, MAN, AQUIB, YOU SEE THIS.
THE PEOPLE SEE THIS.
YOU SAY YOU OWE MONEY.
YOU TRY TO WIN.
SO TALK TO US.
>> YEAH.
HOLD UP.
MY BAD.
BEFORE I GET YOUR PICK, BEFORE I
GET YOUR PICK, I NEED THE PEOPLE
IN THE COMMENTS.
I NEED Y'ALL IN THE COMMENTS TO
TELL ME WHO YOU THINK IS SCORING
THE MOST RUSHING TOUCHDOWNS THIS
YEAR.
I'M GIVING OUT $150 JERSEY GIFT
CARD TO THE ANYBODY TO A PERSON
WHO MATCHES THE RIGHT ANSWER AS
MY GUY AQUIB TALIB.
SO YOU GOT TO GET THE SAME
ANSWER MY GUY IN ORDER TO WIN
THIS JERSEY GIFT DARD.
AQUIB, WHO DO YOU HAVE LEADING
THE LEAGUE IN RUSHING TOUCHDOWNS
THIS YEAR?
>> WHEN I LOOK AT THE LIST,
RIGHT WITHIN I LOOK AT AARON
JONES.
THAT'S WHAT I REALLY LIKE.
IF I BET I WANT TO WIN
SOMETHING.
I BET.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
I'M GOING TO BE SAFE HERE.
I'M GOING TO BE SAFE.
DEREK HENRY.
GOING WITH HENRY, BABY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
VINCE WHAB DO YOU THINK?
>> PLUS 450.
MAKE IT WORK.
>> YEAH.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE LOSING NO
MONEY NOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ALL RIGHT.
MY BOY AQUIB SAID DEREK HENRY.
YOU HAVE TO BE HAPPY WITH THAT,
RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
I'M PROUD.
VERY PROUD OF MY GUY IN DALLAS.
SO, YEAH.
I'M GOING WITH THE SAME THING.
I'M GOING WITH HENRY, TOO.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT.
I THINK I GAVE HIM ENOUGH TIME
IN THE COMMENTS TO COME AND SO
LET'S HOP IN HERE.
AND THE iPAD IS OUT AND THE iPAD
IS OUT AND, OH, MY BOY AQUIB
SAID DEREK HENRY.
SOMEONE WHO TOOK DEREK HENRY IS
WALKING AWAY WITH $150 GIFT
CARD.
I'M ABOUT TO GET INTO THE
COMMENTS NOW.
OH!
HERE WE GO.
I GOT JOSH LOPEZ IS BACK IN THE
COMMENTS TALKING ABOUT DEREK
HENRY.
YOU'RE NOT WALKING AWAY WITH THE
$150.
NO, JOSH.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, BUDDY.
I HAVE JOHN CRY 08 ALSO ROCKING
HENRY IS TAKING OVER THE
COMMENTS.
>> YEAH.
SHOT YOU TO THE TO YOU.
HE'S WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
IT'S TIME TO GIVEAWAY THIS
JERSEY.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
D CARR 3.
D CARR 3 PICKED DEREK HENRY.
THEREFORE YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH THE JERSEY GIFT CARD.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
>> WE HAVE A LOT MORE TO
GIVEAWAY INCLUDING A TRIP TO LAS
VEGAS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU WANT TO STICK AROUND.
>> YEAH.
>> AND MORE.
AS MUCH AS VINCE WANTS THE TRIP,
WE'RE NOT GIVING IT TO VINCE OR
AQUIB.
HE'LL GET THE TRIP THERE.
>> YEAH.
YOU CENTER TO WIN.
KEEP THE MOVING AND TALK PASSING
YARDS.
PASSING YARDS TOTALS
OVER/UNDERS.
OBVIOUSLY PATRICK MAHOMES AND
TOM BRADY AT THE TOP THERE WITH
HUGE EXPECTATIONS THIS YEAR.
SOMEBODY WHO HAS DONE IT FOR A
LONG TIME IN MATT RYAN.
AND THEN A NEWCOMER IN JUSTIN
HERBERT.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU NEED FROM THE
PEOPLE NOW?
I KNOW THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT TAKES ON THIS ONE.
IT'S NOT DEREK HENRY RUSHING
TOUCHDOWNS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT ACROSS THE BOARD.
>> HEY.
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO IN
THE DEPENDS IS USE YOUR TWITTER
FINGERS.
USE YOUR INDRAFT STAY GRAM
BLEACHER REPORT FINGERS.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
YOUR BEST BET FOR PASSING YARDS
TOTAL.
YOU CAN PELL TELL ME IN WORDS OR
GIFS OR E MMOJIS.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND $250
BK DOLLARS.
I'M TALKING TO YOU.
WHO DO YOU THINK HAS THE BEST
VALUE FOR THE TOTAL PASSING YARD
BET?
>> WHAT IS ANOTHER EASY BET?
I KNOW Y'ALL ABOUT TO GET THE
KANSAS CITY CHIEFS, RIGHT?
YOU SEE.
>> THAT'S ANOTHER THING.
>> WHO ARE YOU ROLLING WITH
HERE?
>> HE RIGHT.
PAT MAHOMES IS THE EASY BET.
THE EASY BET.
YOU DON'T PICK UP NO MONEY.
KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
YOU PICK UP THE MONEY YOU BET.
THEREFORE OOICHLT GOING MATT
RYAN.
I'M GOING MATT RYAN.
OVER.
MATT RYAN OVER.
THE WEAPON.
YOUNG NEW WEAPON.
THEY'RE GOING TO THROW IT AROUND
ALL GAME.
THAT'S WHY HE'S GOING LEAD THE
LEAGUE.
>> NO.
>> YEAH.
I'M GOING WITH DAK PRESCOTT.
ON AND ON AND ON I'M GOING WITH
THE SAVE MONEY THERE.
ALL RIGHT, GREG.
BEFORE WE GET TO YOUR PICK, WHAT
ARE THE PEOPLE SAYING NOW?
>> YES, I'M IN THE DEPENDS.
THE iPAD IS BACK IN MY HAND.
B LAWER IS SAYS JOSH ALLEN.
IT MIGHT BE A GOOD BET.
I JUST LOST -- OH, MAN.
JAY.
I LOST YOU MAN, THE COMMENTS ARE
GOING.
NOT RED WARNER 55.
JUSTIN HERBERT.
I DON'T DISLIKE THAT.
HE'S A SHRINKER.
HERBERT IS A SHRINKER.
I GOT ONE MORE HOODIE.
I'M GIVING AWAY ONE MORE HOODIE.
HERE WE GO.
STEVEN DE JONGE ROGERS A BIG
YEAR FROM AARON RODGERS.
ALL RIGHT.
AARON RODGERS.
BEFORE I GIVEAWAY THE 250 DK
DOLLARS, LET ME HOP IN.
I'M GOING WITH TOM BRADY.
WE'RE GOING UNDER.
SUPER BOWL HANG OVER IS A THING.
IT IS A THING.
MY GUY TOM, LISTEN TO ME.
HE THREW FOR 4,633 YARDS LAST
YEAR!
>> DON'T BREAK THAT.
>> DO NOT BET AGAINST TOM BRADY.
>> NO.
>> NEVER AGAIN.
>> YEAH.
>> IT DON'T MATTER, THOUGH.
>> NEVER AGAIN.
NEVER AGAIN.
OH, MAN.
>> WHAT WERE THEY SAYING IN THE
COMMENTS, MAN?
I WANT TO SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE
ARE SAYING.
>> HEY, THE PEOPLE THEY ALL,
MAN, HEY, MAN, AQUIB WANT TO
GIVE ME MORE HOODIES.
I'M GIVING MORE HOODIES OUT.
I GOT PATTY MAHOMES.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
HERE WE GO.
GREG SAID MATT STAFFORD.
MATT STAFFORD SHOUTOUT TO YOU
FOR A HOODIE.
RIGHT NOW I'M GIVING AWAY $250
DK DOLLARS.
HERE WE GO.
250 DK DOLLARS.
M I'M SHOWING HIM LOVE.
I'M SHOWING HIM LOVE BY $250 DK
DOLLARS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
I LOST YOU.
>> VISIT FOR MORE PASSING YARDS.
WE'LL KEEP IT MOVING.
IF YOU DIDN'T GET THE DK
DOLLARS, I'M SURE WE GOT A
JERSEY IN STORE FOR YOU.
MAYBE A HOODIE.
WHAT IS NEXT ON THE GIVEAWAY
LIST?
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT NOW?
>> BAD SPORTS PICK WAS THE
PERSON.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
>> WHO HAS THE MOST PASSING
TOUCHDOWNS THIS YEAR?
LET'S TAKE AK LOOK AT THE ODDS?
>> THERE IT IS.
THERE IT IS.
I'M ASSUMING HE'LL GO WITH THE
100 PICK.
>> OH!
>> YEAH.
I LIKE TO COME HOME WITH
SOMETHING.
>> THEY CALL YOU A FAVORITE.
Y'ALL KNOW WHAT TO DO.
IN THE COMMENTS TELL ME WHO YOU
THINK IS THROWING THE MOST
PASSING TOUCHDOWNS.
I'M GIVING AWAY $150 JERSEY GIFT
CARD TO ONE PERSON WHO MATCHES
MY GUY'S ANSWERS.
SO THE PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW WHO
YOU PICKING?
>> TOM BRADY.
COME ON NOW.
>> OH!
>> DID Y'ALL WATCH HIM?
ANY TIME HE GETS IN THE RED
ZONE, HE HAS TWO BIG GUYS HE CAN
THROW THE BALL TO.
I DON'T NEED TO SAY THEIR NAME.
YOU KNOW THEIR NAME.
ONE PLAY TIGHT END AND ONE WIDE
OUT.
THEY ARE DEADLY IN THE RED ZONE.
>> HEY, LET'S THROW IT BACK ONE
MORE TIME.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE PASSING
TOUCHDOWNS RIGHT HERE.
TOM BRADY PRETTY HIGH AT THE
TOP.
OF COURSE, PATRICK MAHOMES, AS
WELL.
VINCE AND AQUIB, LOOKING AT THE
SKIES, WHETHER IT'S MATT
STAFFORD OR DAK PRESCOTT.
YOU CAN MAKE BANK OFF THAT FOR A
GUY THAT MIGHT WIN COMEBACK
PLAYER OF THE YEAR.
WHO ARE DARK HORSE CANDIDATES
YOU LIKE ON THE LIST?
>> I LIKE STAFFORD, MAN.
STAFFORD GOT A CHANCE.
THINK ABOUT IT.
THE RAMS HAVE NEAR 30 A GAME.
CRANK UP THE PASSING PORTION OF
IT.
THEY RUN ALL THE REVERSES AND
THE SWEEPS.
THEM PASSES.
YOU KNOW THOSE.
THEY SCORE IT.
SEVEN TOUCHDOWNS AND YOU'RE OFF
THOSE.
YOU KNOW THE RAMS OFFENSE.
SO, I DON'T KNOW.
STAFFORD GOT A CHANCE, MAN.
IT'S A HIGH POWERED OFFENSE.
THE OFFENSE ALWAYS SCORE A BUNCH
OF POINTS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> YOU GOT ANOTHER ONE?
>> YEAH.
I GOT DAK, MAN.
HE'S BACK AND READY.
I KNOW HE'S COMPETED!
HE'S EXCITED.
LIKE YOU SAID EARLIER, ALL THE
GUYS HE CAN THROW THE BALL TO.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> SO I'M HAPPY TO SEE HIM BACK.
THAT'S MY DARK HORSE.
>> WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE SAYING
NOW?
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE PEOPLE
ARE IN THE COMMENTS WITH, MAN.
LOOK AT BR BETTING AND THEY SAID
TALIB LIKES STAFFORD.
I GUY WITH WATER IS BACK.
LW JOE BURROW.
JOE?
>> JOE.
>> THAT'S A DARK HORSE.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> BUTTLY ME GET BACK TO THE
MATTER AT HAND.
THE MATTER AT HAND.
THE NFL LEGEND SAID TOM BRADY.
SO SOMEONE WHO TOOK TOM BRADY IS
WALKING AWAY WITH $150 JERSEY
GIFT CARD.
I'M GOING GET INTO THE COMMENTS
AGAIN TO FIGURE OUT WHO I'M
GOING GIVE THIS JERSEY GIFT CARD
TO.
K 3 N 2320.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I'M GIVING IT 0 SOMEBODY ELSE.
>> I SEE.
I SEE AGR 60.
AGR 60.
THEY PICKED TOM BRADY.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY, MAN.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
AGR 60.
>> I LOVE IT.
WE'RE NOT DONE GIVING AWAY STUFF
YET.
YOU'VE HEARD FROM US ON PASSING
AND RUSHING LEADERS.
I GOT TO TALK TO DRAFT KINGS
ANALYST REID FOWLER FOR SOME
TAKES OF HIS OWN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WELCOME TO "THE SQUAD."
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON.
WE WANT TO GO THROUGH SOME
PLAYERS TO WATCH TO LEAD IN A
LOT OF DIFFERENT CATEGORIES.
WE START WITH THE RUNNING BACKS.
WHO DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO
TAKE HOME THE RUSHING TITLE THIS
YEAR AND HAVE THE MOST RUSHING
TOUCHDOWNS?
>> YEAH, CONNOR, I THINK DEREK
HENRY.
DON'T MAKE IT HARD.
RIGHT.
KEEP IT SIMPLE.
ALL RIGHT.
AND ESPECIALLY LIKE A FINE WINE.
HE GETS BETTER AS TIME
PROGRESSES.
IF YOU LOOK AT HIS
NOVEMBER/DECEMBER YARDS IN THE
TWO MONTHS WHERE OTHER GUYS
MIGHT BE GETTING COLD OR HURT.
HE HAS AROUND 3500 YARDSED IN
THE TWO MONTHS COMBINED IN HIS
CAREER.
SO KEEP IT SIMPLE.
GO DEREK HENRY PLUS 350.
"T-D"s.
I'M GOING A LITTLE BIT OFF.
MAYBE NOT TOO MUCH OFF THE RADAR
BUT ANTONIO GIBSON PLUS 1800.
SEVENTH IN RUSHING TOUCHDOWNS
DESPITE STARTING, I THINK, TEN
GAMES LAST YEAR AND PLAYING ONLY
14.
THE GUY HAS A GREAT DEFENSE
BEHIND HIM.
YOU KNOW, I THINK HE'S HALL OF
FAME QUARTERBACK.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T AGREE WITH
THAT.
ANTONIO GIBSON PLUS 1800.
>> YEAH.
I LIKE THE VOLUME FROM BOTH OF
THE GUYS.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A BIG
SECOND YEAR FOR GIBSON.
KEEP IT SCHISM.
DON'T OVER THINK HENRY.
MOVING ON TO THE QUARTERBACKS.
LOOKING AT WHO ARE WE KEEPING AN
EYE ON FOR PASSING TITLE THE
MOST YARDS AND PASSING
TOUCHDOWNS THIS YEAR?
>> YEAH.
I'M WITH JUSTIN HERBERT PLUS 14
U 00.
THERE'S A LOT OF GUYS YOU CAN
TAKE.
THIS HAS A LOT TO DEAL WITH
SCHEME AND THE DEFENSE ISN'T
THAT GREAT.
I THINK MATT RYAN MIGHT BE A
NICE PLAY FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
BUT WE'LL TALK ABOUT HIM IN A
LITTLE BIT BUT JUSTIN HERBERT
5,000 YARDS IS PROBABLY THE
MARKET GOING TO HAVE TO GET
OVER.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE EXTRA GAME.
HERBERT WAS 289, I BELIEVE,
289.1 YARDS PER GAME LAST YEAR.
IF YOU GIVE UP FIVE MORE YARDS
PER GAME THIS YEAR, HE GETS TO
THE 5,000 MARK.
ESPECIALLY WITH HECKLER HEALTHY,
IT WAS A HUGE MISS FOR HERBERT
LAST YEAR.
AND THIS GUY YOU KNOW WE SEE HIM
IN WINS, TOO.
AVERAGE 25 YARDS MORE THAN IN
LOSSES.
THE CHARGERS, EVEN IF THEY'RE
UP, THEY'RE STILL PASSING.
THEY HAVE A RUNNING BACK THAT
CAN KIND OF SEAL GAMES DOWN LIKE
DEREK HENRY.
I THINK JUSTIN HERBERT IS FINE
AT PLUS 1400.
I THINK HE'LL HAVE A GREAT
SEASON.
AGAIN, GOING BACK TO THE PASSING
TOUCHDOWNS.
JOSH ALLEN AT PLUS 750.
I THINK THAT'S HUGE FOR JOSH
ALLEN TO CONTINUE WHAT THEY DID
LAST YEAR AND STEPH DIGGS IS
FANTASTIC.
I KNOW YOU CAN POTENTIALLY BUT
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS 41.6 IS
THE TOUCHDOWN TOTAL THAT LEAD.
MA HOLMES GOT TO 50.
I THINK JOSH ALLEN GET AROUND
THE MID 40s.
I THINK THAT GOOD ENOUGH THIS
YEAR.
>> YEAH.
TWO GUYS COMING OFF HUGE BREAK
OFF SEASONS.
JOSH ALLEN AND RYAN THERE.
WANT CONTINUITY HAS BEEN PRETTY
SPECIAL TO WATCH.
WHO IS GOING TO TAKE HOME THE
TITLE OF MOST RECEIVING YARDS
1234 AND THIS COULD BE MUCH
DIFFERENT.
WHO WILL CATCH THE MOST
TOUCHDOWNS?
WHO IS GETTING THE MOST IN THE
RED ZONES HERE?
>> YEAH.
CALVIN RIDLEY MIGHT HAVE A
THOUSAND -- A MILLION TARGETS
THIS YEAR.
I MEAN, WHO ELSE YOU GOING TO
PASS TO IN THE OFFENSE.
GIVING MATT RYAN A COUPLE MORE
YEARS.
A LITTLE EXTRA FOR THE GUY.
LOOK, HONESTLY, WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT YARDS.
YOU TALK ABOUT QUARTERBACKS.
MATT RYAN HAS IT CLOSE TO SOME
OF THESE BUT RIDLEY IS A GUY WHO
IS 15 YARDS LAST SEASON.
HAD EIGHT 100-YAFRD GAMES.
IT RANKED FIRST IN THE NFL.
AND HE AVERAGED NINE TARGETS.
WHEN YOU PUT THOSE TOGETHER,
IT'S REALLY SETTING UP FOR
CALVIN RIDLEY TO TAKE THAT
NUMBER ONE.
AND EVEN THOUGH I DO THINK THAT,
AGAIN, THEY HAVE TO SCORE A LOT
OF TOUCHDOWN FOR ATLANTA TO KEEP
UP.
I THINK DIGGS WITH ALLEN AT PLUS
1600 TO HAVE THE MOST
TOUCHDOWNS.
YOU KNOW THIS BETTER THAN
ANYONE, CONNOR, TARGETS THE ONLY
THING WE CAN'T PREDICT QUOTE,
UNQUOTE, PREDICT IN THE NFL.
AND DIGGS HE'S GOING TO GET A
LOT OF TARGETS.
I'M NOT TOO WORRIED ABOUT THE
OTHER GUYS IN THE OFFENSE IN
TERMS OF WHAT ALLEN WANTS TO DO
AND WHAT BRIAN WANTS TO DO DOWN
FIELD.
THAT'S DIGGS.
160 PROJECTED FINISH THIS YEAR.
AGAIN, PUT HIM AT 9 OR 10
TARGETS A GAME.
FROM A VALUE PERSPECTIVE, I
THINK DIGGS IS THE BEST RIGHT
NOW.
>> YEAH.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
>> THANKS.
>>> IT'S GREAT TO TALK TO REID.
TIME TO BRICK IT BACK HERE.
WE'LL TALK PLAYER AWARDS AND
START WITH MOST IMPORTANT ONE.
WHAT ARE THE ODDS TO WIN THE MVP
AWARD?
OBVIOUSLY YOU SEEM MAHOMES AT TE
TOP.
st TH-- THAT'S BEEN A THEME.
THAT'S AARON RODGERS.
AND BIG TIME RISER JOSH ALLEN.
YOU HAVE JUSTIN HERBERT AT THE
BOTTOM.
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE
COMMENTS, GREG?
WHAT DO WE NEED FROM THE PEOPLE
AS WE GET READY TO GIVEAWAY THE
LAS VEGAS TRIP?
>> EVERYBODY IS GET COMMENTS AND
TELL US YOUR BEST BET FOR MVP.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND 250
DK DOLLARS.
WHO DO YOU THINK IS THE BEST BET
TO WIN?
>> I'M GOING WITH MY GUY MR.
WILSON.
I THINK THIS YEAR HE'S GOING TO
FINALLY GET OVER AND GO HOME AND
HAVE A BETTER PLAYOFF AND
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME TO GET THE
MVP.
I'M GOING WITH MY GUY MR.
WILSON.
>> MR. WILSON.
>> AQUIB, WHAT ARE YOU GOING
WITH?
>> I'M GOING RIDE WITH TOMMY.
TOMMY.
MAN, HE CAUGHT HIS STRIDE LAST
YEAR IN THE SECOND HALF OF THE
SEASON INTO THE END OF THE
SEASON.
I THINK HE PICK UP WHERE HE LEFT
OFF, KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
GOT THE HIGH POWERED OFFENSE AND
A BUNCH OF DEEP BALLS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING, HE GOT
IT FIGURED OUT.
NOW HOE HE'S GOING GET HIS
RECEIVERS THE BALL AND EVERY
INDIVIDUAL GUY THE BALL.
>> THEY LIKE TO WIN A LOT OF
GAMES.
I THINK MAHOMES OFF THE SUPER
BOWL LOSS AND GREAT WEAPONS
THERE.
ESPECIALLY TYRIQ HILL.
HE'LL MAKE IT HAPPEN THIS YEAR.
BUT, GREG, BEFORE WE GET TO YOUR
TAKE, THE COMMENTS AGREEING WITH
WHAT RIGHT NOW?
>> LET ME SEE.
>> OH.
>> I'M SAYING THIS.
>> MR. WILSON IS WRONG.
>> YEAH.
>> I'M SEEING RUSSELL WILSON MVP
RICHIE 21 SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT LAMAR JACKSON.
LAMAR JACKSON.
OH.
LAMAR JACKSON I'M PRETTY SURE I
CAN'T PRONOUNCE THIS.
EVERYBODY IS WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE IF I SAY YOUR NAME.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
GETS THE ROLL CALL.
BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
I SEE ROGERS.
>> NO , SIR.
>> THAT'S IT FOR THE HOODIES
RIGHT NOW.
LET ME HOP IN HERE, Y'ALL.
I'M GOING WITH JOSH ALLEN.
STEP OUT OF THE BOX A LITTLE
BIT.
MY GUY TALIB SAID HE LIKES
VALUE.
HE LIKES MONEY.
JOSH ALLEN IS TOWARD THE BOTTOM
OF THE LIST.
YOU KNOW, I'M GOING TO ROLL THE
DICE.
MY GUY JOSH ALLEN IS TOP FIVE IN
PASSING YARDS LAST YEAR.
TOP FIVE IN PASSING YARDS LAST
YEAR.
TOP FIVE IN PASSING TOUCHDOWNS
AND RUSHED FOR EIGHT TOUCHDOWNS.
I THINK HE'LL TAKE THE GAME UP
AND HOPEFULLY, YOU KNOW, WIN THE
MVP.
I PUT MY MONEY THERE.
>> YEAH.
>> HE'S A BEAST.
HE'S A BEAST.
>> YEAH.
LET ME GET BACK INTO THE
COMMENTS AND GIVEAWAY THIS 250
BK DOLLARS.
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS I'M
BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
AND I SEE HERE WE GO.
ERIC BRIDGES.
HE SAID JOSH ALLEN IS A SOLID
PICK.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, BROTHER.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
>> HEY.
>> HE WALKS AWAY WITH $250.
>> HEY, THANKS.
>> SHOUTOUT.
VISIT DRAFT KINGS FOR MORE MVP
ODDS.
IF YOU HAVEN'T WON YET, GIVE
GREG A COMPLIMENT AND YOU'LL
PROBABLY WALK AWAY WITH
SOMETHING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> DON'T TELL THEM THE SAUCE.
>> BEFORE I TAP IN AND ASK FOR
HIS PICK FOR ROOKIE OF THE YEAR,
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS
FOR THE ROOKIE THE YEAR.
OH, MAN.
IT'S QUITING.
WE GOT TREVOR LAWRENCE UP TOP.
JUSTIN FIELDS AND TREY LANCE.
LOOK AT TREY LANCE PLUS 750.
I LIKE THAT.
IMAGI
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
WHO YOU THINK IS SCORING -- YOU
KNOW, ACTUALLY, TELL ME WHO YOU
THINK IS WINNING OFFENSIVE
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
TELL ME WHO YOU THINK IS WINNING
OFFENSIVE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
OH, BY?
>> YES, SIR.
YES, SIR?
>> THE PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW --
THE PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW WHO DO
YOU THINK -- ACTUALLY, THE
PRUTSER SAID THE PEOPLE WANT TO
KNOW WHO DO YOU THINK IS WINNING
OFFENSIVE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR?
>> MY MAN ZACH.
I LIKE HIS DECISION MAKING HE
MADE AT PRESEASON.
THE YOUNG MAN WAS ON THE BALL.
VERY GOOD.
ALSO NO TURNOVERS.
SO THAT'S PRETTY GOOD!
IT'S KIND OF TOUGH, TOO.
SOME OF THE OTHER GUYS ARE NOT
EVEN PLAYING YET.
I THINK JUSTIN SHOULD BE
STARTING.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THIS OTHER GUY
IS STARTING HERE.
I WOULDN'T PLAY HIM.
IT'S THE PROBLEM.
YOU SAID IT.
JUSTIN FIELDS TRAY LANCE AND NOT
STARTING.
AND PITHS PROBABLY GOING TO SEAL
OUT TARGET.
MAC JONES IS THE OFFICIALLY
STARTER IN NEW ENGLAND.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S HEAR FROM YOU.
WHO DO YOU LIKE ON THIS LIST?
>> MAC JONES!
FIRST HE'S GOING TO PICK UP.
PLUS 1,000.
SOLID COORDINATOR.
HE GOT A SOLID TEAM AROUND THEM.
SO I LIKE THE SQUAD.
HE GOT AROUND THEM.
JOSH McDANIELS GOING TO MAKE IT
EASY FOR HIM.
HE'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
BALL OUT OF THE HANDS FAST, RUN
THE FOOTBALL, PLAY DEFENSE.
SO THE WIN TOTAL.
THE WIN TOTAL AND THE STATS.
>> WHAT DO THE PEOPLE THINK?
>> YEAH.
THE PEOPLE ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
I WANT TO GIVEAWAY HOODIES.
THE PEOPLE ARE HERE.
I GOT HIM OUT.
NAGI OUT.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT GAME PRO.
YOU'RE AWAYING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
AND I THINK IT'S TIME.
I THINK IT'S TIME.
BY SAID ZACK WILSON.
SO SOMEBODY SAID ZACK WILSON IS
WALKING AWAY WITH $150 JERSEY
GIFT CARD.
BACK TO THE iPAD NOW.
LOOKING FOR THE LUCKY
CONTESTANT.
AND I CAME ACROSS LATER 909 --
RAIDER 990.
BUT RAIDER 909 I'M NOT NO HATER.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH $150
JERSEY DOLLARS.
>> SPEAKING OF MVP AND ROOKIE OF
THE YEAR.
I HAD A CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH THE
DIRECTOR OF DRAFT KING
SPORTSBOOK ON THE LATEST TRENDS
AROUND THESE MARKETS AND THE
BETTING WORLD.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JOHNNY, WELCOME TO THE SQUAD.
REALLY HAPPY TO HAVE YOU HERE.
I KNOW YOU HAVE THE INSIDE SCOOP
ON EVERYTHING GOING ON IN THE
NFL BETTING WORLD.
I WANT TO START WITH PROBABLY
THE MOST PRESTIGIOUS BUT THE
MOST SIMPLE.
WHAT ARE THE MOST POPULAR BETS
FOR THE MVP NOW?
ARE THERE ANY SURPRISING NAMES
FINDING THEMSELVES IN THE MIX?
>> THE MOST POPULAR WOULD BE
PATRICK MAHOMES AT 5-1 WITH 20%
OF ALL THE MONEY IN THAT MARKET.
MAHOMES WAS A TOP WAGER.
LAST SEASON TOLD AARON RODGERS
OF THE PACKERS JUMPED ON THE
REIGNING MVP.
AND APPROXIMATELY HALF WAY
THROUGH THE SEASON.
MATTHEW STAFFORD IS YET TO WIN
ANYTHING IN THE 12 YEAR NFL
CAREER.
TAKING ABOUT 12% OF THE MONEY.
TAKING ABOUT 18-1.
AND JUSTIN HERBERT A NOTABLE
SECOND YEAR IS ANOTHER BETTER IS
BACKING SPECULATING ON HAVING
JUST THE TOP SEASON.
HERBERT ALSO 18-1.
AND IF YOU NOTICE THAT ALL THE
GUYS TOP 10 GUYS IN THE MARKET
THEY'RE ALL QUARTERBACKS AND IT
MAKES SENSE, BECAUSE
QUARTERBACKS AT 117 OF THE LAST
20.
>> YEAH.
AND HERBERT COMING OFF THE
PHENOMENAL ROOKIE SEASON AND
KICKING THINGS TO THE ROOKIES
NOW.
I'M CALLING THIS THE JUSTIN
FIELDS SHOW.
SO FAR FIELDS IS TAKING 36% OF
THE MONEY.
50% OF THE BETS.
PARTICULARLY THE QUARTERBACK.
HE APPEARS TO BE THE TEAM GOING
TO BE WIN QUITE A FEW GAMES.
ALL THOUGH HE -- START IN WEEK
ONE.
HE SHOULD BE AT THE HEAD CONTROL
SHORTLY INTO THE SEASON.
>> YEAH.
INTERESTING.
THAT MARKET IS WIDE OPEN.
LOOKING AT ALL THE WAGERS NOW,
IS THERE ANY LINE THAT HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY MOVED SINCE IT
LAUNCHED OR ARE THERE A COUPLE
OF LINES YOU'VE SEEN A LOT OF
MOVEMENT ON SINCE THEY WENT
LIVE?
>> THERE'S TWO WITH GOOD
MOVEMENT.
THE FIRST IS THE SEAHAWKS AT THE
COLTS.
THE COLTS OPEN THE 1.5 FAVORITE
AND NOW 2.5 UNDERDOG.
IT'S BASED ON A COMBINATION OF
QUARTERBACK UNCERTAINTY AND
THAT'S CARSON WENTZ AT HANDICAP
AND THE SEAHAWKS ARE PERCEIVED
AS THE BEFORE THE TEAM.
THE SECOND GAME SUBSTANTIAL
MOVEMENT INVOLVES THE WASHINGTON
FOOTBALL TEAM WHO OPEN AS A 1.5
HOME FAVORITE OVER THE CHARGERS
AND THE L.A. TEAM HAS TAKING
OVER FAVORITISM BY ONE POINT.
THIS IS STRICTLY A HANDICAP MOVE
WITH A BETTER SIDING WITH JUSTIN
HERBERT OVER PROBABLE RYAN FI
FITZPATRICK.
>> YOU'VE BEEN DOING THAT FOR A
LOT OF TIMES AND DRAFT KINGS IS
OFFERING A LOT OF NEW.
WHAT IS THE MOST POPULAR ALONG
THE NEW MARKETS YOU'VE SEEN.
>> THE REGULAR SEASON MATCH UPS
ARE DOING A POPULAR FOR.
FOR INSTANCE PASSING CATEGORY.
>> SO WE HAVE 6-10 MATCH UPS IN
MULTIPLE CATEGORIES AND IT'S
GOING ON FIRE.
>> I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> BIG THANKS TO JOHNNY.
YOU HEARD IT.
JUSTIN FIELDS BETTERS ARE
PROBABLY NOT TOO HAPPY ABOUT THE
LATEST NEWS THAT THE MAN SOMEHOW
IS NOT STARTING.
>> THE DIVISION WINNERS.
I'M SURE THE AUDIENCE WILL BE
RATIONAL ON PICKING THESE.
LET'S BRING UP THE ODDS AND TAKE
A LOOK AT THE AFC AND SEE WHO IS
AND EFFECTED TO COME OUT ON TOP.
IN THE AFC.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU CAN SEE ACROSS THE BOARD
THAT THE AFC NORTH PRETTY MUCH
WIDE OPEN RIGHT NOW.
BESIDES THOSE POOR BENGALS DOWN
AT THE BOTTOM.
THE AFC EAST THE BILLS EXPECTED
TO REIGN SUPREME.
DON'T SLEEP ON THOSE DOLPHINS
WHO ARE THE MAC JONES LEAD
PATRIOTS.
OUT WEST I DON'T THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE WILL BE BETTING AGAINST
THE CHIEFS ANY TIME SOON.
YOU LOOK AT THE SOUTH, HOUSTON
HAS PLENTY OF PROBLEMS OF THEIR
OWN.
JACKSONVILLE WITH THE ROOKIE.
TITANS AT THE TOP OVER THERE.
MOVING ON TO THE NFC.
LET'S SEE THE NFC ODDS BEFORE WE
GET THE EXPERT PICKS HERE.
AARON RODGERS IS BACK AND
SITTING NICE.
YOU LOOK AT THE SOUTH.
NOT GOING TO BE A LOT OF PICKS
AGAINST TOM BRADY AND THE BUCS.
THE NFC EAST WIDE OPEN.
COWBOYS WITH DAK PRESCOTT AND
THE WASHINGTON FOOTBALL TEAM AND
MAYBE THE GIANTS.
ALL RIGHT.
NFC WEST SAME THING.
WIDE OPEN.
NINERS, RAMS, SEAHAWKS IN THE
MIX.
THE CARDINALS AS THE UNDERDOG.
GREG, WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE GOT
GOING ON NOW?
I LOVE TO HEAR THEIR THOUGHTS.
>> EVERYBODY GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND TELL US WHICH TEAM IS THE
BEST BET TO WIN THE DIVISION.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND 250
DK DOLLARS.
MEANWHILE, WHICH TEAM DO YOU
THINK IS THE BEST BET TO WIN?
>> TITANS, FOR SURE.
>> YEAH.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO RUN THE
SHOW.
>> YEAH.
CIGARETTE THE BALL TO THE BIG
MONEY AND YOU'VE GOT TWO HAMMER
HEAD SHARKS.
JUST TAKE YOUR TIME AND HAVE FUN
FOR THE GAME.
THE TALENTED GUYS HE HAS AROUND
HIM.
>> WHO ARE YOU ROLLING WITH?
I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE GOING TO PICK
A DARK HORSE HERE.
>> YEAH.
A DARK HORSE, MAN.
BECAUSE HE'S KEEPING IT SO
SIMPLE.
>> THEIR GOING TO SEND THREE TO
THE PLAYOFFS.
THEY'LL HAVE A BUNCH.
I'M GOING WITH ARIZONA TO BE THE
12-OH, WITH A IS IT NOW?
12 -- 13-4.
ARIZONA 13-4.
>> I AIN'T SAID WHAT THREE
TEAMS.
THEY'RE GOING TO SEND THREE
YES.
ONE OF THING GOING TO HAVE THE
INJURY BUG.
OUT'RE THREE TEAMS GO ON HIM.
>> I'LL TELL YOU A DIVISION NOT
SENDING THREE TEAMS.
THAT'S NFC NORTH.
THEY HAVE ONE TEAM.
THAT'S THE PACKERS.
I'M ROLLING WITH THEM.
I'M NOT BUYING IN ON KIRK
COUSINS.
I WISH THE BEARS WOULD START
JUSTIN FIELDS.
I MEAN, THIS IS A PRETTY MUCH A
RUN AWAY.
THE LIONS, SORRY.
>> BEFORE I GIVE YOU MY TAKE.
LET ME TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
LET ME GIVE THE PEOPLE'S TAKES.
HERE WE GO.
I GOT KEVIN ROCKING WITH THE
RAIDERS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
AND HERE WE GO.
HAWAII 77 SAYS EAGLES, BABY.
EAGLES.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
>> FLY EAGLES, FLY.
>> I JUST HAD TO READ THAT ONE
FOR YOU.
THAT WAS FOR YOU.
>> SPEAKING OF THE AFC EAST.
I'M GOING THERE.
I'M GOING THERE AND LOOKING AT
BUFFALO.
I'M LOOKING AT BUFFALO.
I THINK I'M GOING ROCK WITH
BUFFALO.
>> YEAH.
BECAUSE, I MEAN, OH, MAN.
THEY'RE A COOL NEW TEAM OUT
THERE.
SIMPLY BECAUSE -- YES, CONNOR.
>> SHOUT OUT TO ROBERT.
BUFFALO AND AQUIB.
WE LIKE WINNERS ONLY.
I THINK THIS HERE IS A WINNER.
SO I TAKE THIS TO THE BANK, MAN.
>> I'M BACK INTO THE iPAD.
iBACK INTO THE iPAD.
RIGHT HERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GET ON DRAFT KINGS FOR MORE
DIVISION WINNERS.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME TO TALK ABOUT
THE DIVISION WINNERS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SUP SUPER
BOWL WINNER.
BEFORE WE DO THAT, A TRIP TO
GIVEAWAY.
AND THAT TRIP IS TO LAVLGS --
LAS VEGAS.
THE MOM YOU'VE BEEN WAITING FOR.
THE MOMENT YOU'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR.
>> TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT WE GOT
NEXT.
>> I KNOW BY AND AQUIB ARE
WAITING FOR IT.
I'LL PUT IT TOGETHER.
RHYME ABOUT TO GIVEAWAY ONE LAST
JERSEY AND A TRIP TO LAS VEGAS.
WHAT I NEED YOU TO DO IS --
>> THAT WAS AN EASY BET.
THAT'S EASY.
EVERYONE DOES THAT.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS TO WIN
IT ALL THIS YEAR.
WE KNEW THE CHIEFS AND THE BUCS
ARE GOING TO SIT AT THE TOP.
GREG IS OFFICIALLY A MEMBER OF
BILLS MAFIA.
PRETTY GOOD MONEY THERE.
>> WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE MONEY
HERE.
WE'RE NOT PLAYING IT SAFE ALL
THE TIME.
>> YEAH.
>> I GOT TO GO WITH IT, MR.
GOAT.
MR. BRADY.
HE'S GOING TO DO IT AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE WINNERS FOR
SOME REASON BUT TOM BRADY IS THE
GUY.
HE'S THE GOAT.
>> YOU KNOW I LIKE TO PICK UP
THE PAPER.
THEY GOT A CHANCE.
I'M GOING WITH THE BEST DEFENSE
IN THE LEAGUE.
>> RIDE WITH THE RAMS.
>> I'M RIDING WITH THE RAMS,
MAN.
>> IF YOU CATCH FIRE IN THE
DEFENSE WHAT THEY ABOUT TO DO,
MAN.
THAT'S A GREAT BET.
>> YEAH.
BIG TIME MONEY FOR THAT.
>> TOUGH TO FIND A BETTER
DEFENSIVE DUO AND THE NFL THAN
THAT.
I'M GOING TO ROLL WITH THE GUYS.
PRETTY NICE OUT THERE.
I'M GOING ROLL WITH IT.
>> THEY'RE COMING OFF A
DISAPPOINTING SUPER BOWL LOSS.
AND DAD IS ON IT PLUS 500.
A COWARD BET.
DON'T CARE.
ROLLING WITH THE CHIEFS.
WHAT DO YOU GOT?
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> BIG BIFRD.
BUFFALO BILLS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
YOU BIG MAD.
ROCKING WITH THE 49ERS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE ALSO WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> LET'S PUT THE GRAPHIC BACK
UP.
LET'S PULL THAT NFL CHAMPIONSHIP
GRAPHIC BACK UP AND WALK THROUGH
IT.
KANSAS CITY CHIEFS PLUS 500.
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO PICK THE
FAVORITE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON.
TAMPA BAY SUPER BOWL HANGOVER.
I'M.
I KNOW YOU BELIEVE IN BRADY.
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING.
BUFFALO.
>> GREEN BAY THEY'RE GOING TO
LOSE TO THE NINERS.
THEY'RE GOING TO SKIP.
BALTIMORE.
OH, LAMAR JACKSON YOU GOT TO
SHOW ME SOMETHING IN THE
POSTSEASON.
SO WE'RE ALSO GOING TO SKIP ON
THEM.
GUESS WHERE WE LAND AT?
SAN FRANCISCO 49ERS.
>> YES.
TRAY LANCE AS QUARTERBACK.
DUAL QUARTERBACK.
WE MIGHT SEE IT.
>> YEAH.
>> THE BIG SHOW.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE GOT HURT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE GOT HURT.
>> WE GOING TO SEE.
WE GOING TO SEE.
LET ME GIVE UP THE JERSEY.
I'M BANG INTO IT.
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
AND I SEE DAVY DB -- HOLD ON.
THE COMMENTS ARE JUMPING.
THEY GOT THE MOVE ON.
>> THAT'S A TOUGH BREAK.
>> I'M A NEW BILLS FAN AND
ROCKING WITH THE NINERS.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
THE BILLS.
DIGGS AND ALLEN ARE COMING BACK.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A GIFT
CARD FOR THE JERSEY.
>> WE WANT TO KNOW WHO IS GOING
TO LAS VEGAS.
SO, GREG, HOW DO THEY WIN THE
LAS VEGAS TRIP?
I'M TRYING TO SET IT UP.
YOU'VE BEEN DEMOCRAT COMMENTS.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THE WILL
OF SPEND WITH ALL 32.
I'M GOING PICK THE TEAM TO WIN
THE TRIP TO LAS VEGAS.
BY, AQUIB, BEFORE I SPEND THIS.
BEFORE WE SPIN THIS, Y'ALL BEEN
TALKING A BIG LAS VEGAS GAME.
Y'ALL TALKING LIKE YOU WANT TO
PULL UP TO LAS VEGAS.
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE TABLE GAME
TO PLAY WHEN YOU ARE AT THE
CASINO?
>> FAVORITE?
>> KEEP IT SIMPLE.
I'M A 21 TYPE OF GUY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> BLACKJACK.
>> SHOUTOUT.
>> Y'ALL READY?
IT'S TIME TO SPIN THIS WILL.
>> LET'S DO IT.
LET'S SEE WHO IS GOING TO LAS
VEGAS.
LET'S DO IT.
>> AQUIB?
Y'ALL READY?
>> YES.
>> HEY.
LET'S DO IT.
LET'S SPIN THIS WHEEL.
SPIN THAT THING.
>> THEY FOUND A GUY FROM OU THAT
PLAYS QUARTERBACK AND YOU KNOW
OU SUCKS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT'S THE SECRET TO THE
MADNESS.
>> NOW I SEE WHY.
NOW I SEE WHY.
YEAH.
PICK THE BROWNS.
SOMEONE WHO TOOK THE BROWNS IS
WALKING AWAY WITH THE TRIP TO
LAS VEGAS.
FOOIL FIND IT IN THE COMMENTS
NOW.
I'M ABOUT TO GET INTO THE
COMMENTS.
HERE WE GO.
HB SHOUT YOU L.A. CHARGERS.
NO.
YOU ARE NOT WINNING THE TRIP.
GUESS WHAT.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
>> HE'S ROCKING WITH THE NINERS.
I LOVE THAT.
I LOVE THAT TO THE CORE.
>> I CANNOT GIVE YOU A TRIP TO
LAS VEGAS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
NICK SMITH 417 BY, YOU GOING TO
LIKE THIS.
TIGHTEN UP.
>> TIGHTEN UP.
>> YEAH.
>> I DON'T FEEL IT IN ME TO GIVE
YOU THE LAS VEGAS TRIP.
I'M GIVING YOU A HOODIE.
>> HERE WE GO.
THIS IS THE LAS VEGAS TRIP HERE.
>> B LAWSER 74 HAD THE BROWNS.
HAD THE BROWNS.
>> YEAH.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
>> GOING TO TAKE THAT.
>> YEAH.
>> I GOT TO SAY THIS.
I GOT TO SAY THIS.
ALL THE LAWYERS WILL GET MAD AND
I MIGHT NOT HAVE MY JOB NEXT
WEEK.
WE DON'T WANT THAT.
>> I THINK EVERYBODY GOT THE
SURPRISES AND A HOODIE AND LAS
VEGAS.
WHATEVER IT MAY BE.
GET ON DRAFT KINGS AND CHECK OUT
EVERYTHING IN YOUR LOCAL MARKETS
AND NOW NO BRAINER.
BUCS PLUS 73.
FREE MONEY.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT MEANS?
IF THE BUCS -- THE BUCKS HAVE TO
DO IS NOT LOSE BY MORE THAN 73
POINTS AND YOU ARE A WINNER!
THAT'S EASY MONEY.
THAT'S A BY PICK.
THAT'S NOT AN EASY PICK.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO HERE.
SQUAD RIDE IS BACK SUNDAY WEEK
ONE 11:00 A.M. EASTERN TIME.
GREG AND I WILL BE BACK BEFORE
KICKOFF IN THE BLEACHER REPORT
APP.
COME SEE US AND GET HOODIES AND
PRIZES AND JERSEYS.
>> WHOA, WHOA.
CONNOR, I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE ABOUT
TO WRAP IT UP.
WE'VE BEEN HERE FOR AWHILE.
BEFORE WE WRAP IT UP, HANDY
DANDY IS BACK OUT.
I'M GIVING A HOODIE.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
HERE WE GO.
DAVY 24 YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH
A HOODIE.
WOLF JESUS IS SAYING -- THE
TAM
TAMPA BAY BUCS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
>> I APOLOGIZE, MAN.
I GOT TO FEED THE PEOPLE.
>> YEAH.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> THANKS TO VINCE YOUNG.
THANKS TO AQUIB TALIB.
>> THAT'S A GOOD IDEA.
I'M CONNOR ROGERS.
>> WHOA, WHOA.
CONNOR, CONNOR --
>> WE GOT TO GIVEAWAY A JERSEY.
WE GOT TO GIVEAWAY A JERSEY.
>> OH, MAN.
BY NEED A HOODIE.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
STEELERS TO WIN IT ALL.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A GIFT
CARD FOR A JERSEY.
>> GO GET THAT HARRIS.
>> I PROMISE YOU.
>> HOLD ON.
HOLD ON.
I THINK WE MIGHT BE GIVING AWAY
SOMETHING ELSE, CONNOR.
HOLD ON.
THE PRODUCER IS WHISPERING
SOMETHING.
WE'RE GIVING MORE MONEY AWAY.
BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
COWBOYS OVER THE BEARS.
LEE ROSS GARZA.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH $250 DK
DOLLARS.
I'M BEING GENEROUS NOW.
I'M BEING GENEROUS RIGHT NOW.
HE'S IN BALL MART TRIPPING NOW.
WE NEED THAT VIDEO.
CONNOR, ALL RIGHT, BRO.
THAT WASN'T ME.
>> I LOVE IT.
I LOVE IT.
THAT WAS IN MY EAR.
THANK YOU FOR KBAWATCHING,
EVERYONE.
CATCH YOU WEEK ONE.